i love cloud functions and cloud run  because they're serverless so they scale  up automatically with increased traffic  but even if you use serverless you may  have to integrate with server full  things this could be a server full  database or an existing server full api  your server less components will scale  up beautifully to handle traffic spikes  but your server full components won't  how to prevent your serverless  components from overwhelming your server  full ones here's how i do it  first i make all communication  asynchronous by using cloud tasks async  just scales better if a return value is  needed i make that a return async call  now i can set a rate limit in cloud  tasks for example max 5 concurrent  outbound calls if there is a spike in  traffic cloud tasks will smooth it out  so my server full components can handle  it without crashing  have you run into any problems when  mixing serverless and server full please  share in the comments